geoff is een daredevil season 2 or
season 3 like season 2 is not as good to
see someone but season 3 dude it takes
it back to season one you've got to get
on that [ __ ] it's just hard to get
invested in shows because you get invest
in the shows then they get cancelled
it's just tough dude it's daredevil on
Netflix pretty sure you got nothing to
worry about that my friends is a real
conversation I had with one of my
friends not two weeks ago I'm sorry I
kind of looked like [ __ ] today I just I
didn't expect to do a video today I just
wanted to relax play some Red Dead
Redemption to time half done with I
don't know why some movies read some
comic books maybe jerk off a couple
times with my brother text me and he's
like dude daredevil was just cancelled
on Netflix I was like bull-fucking-shit
then I looked into it I'm like alright
let's set up the camera and yeah you
didn't miss hear me daredevil is
cancelled I know Netflix already sliced
the throats of Iron Fist and Luke Cage
wish I understood those getting the axe
but I was like or as long as daredevil
doesn't get sliced I think we're fine
that won't happen until after Jessica
Jones gets canceled no I guess
Daredevils the next to go like
Daredevils cancelled now and I
understand the viewership and like the
first week of season 3 was down 57% from
the first week of season 2 or something
like that and I feel like that's more
reflective of how people receive season
2 I feel like a lot of people were like
see what my friends say but damn I guess
it's gone Jessica Jones you're number
one now I guess well that is a Punisher
one of you twos number one now you're
number one in the sense that maverick
and Top Gun was number one in which
you're number two like maverick was
number two and then cougar turned in his
wings in which maverick became number
ones like that only instead of cougar
turning in his wings imagine mr.
Strickland shot him in the head and I
don't know any of the business element I
have Farish I really do because I've
heard that daredevil might live on but
elsewhere not on Netflix don't know what
that means could mean it might be coming
to the MCU more likely means it might be
coming to the Disney streaming service
not a huge leap Disney owns Marvel
daredevil is Marvel so I don't know who
if anyone's whispering in the ear of who
I don't know who's taking action based
on the whispers if any but couldn't you
see that like couldn't you just see it
like oh we have our new streaming
service coming out and gee whiz we'd
really like daredevil to be a part of it
so kill it on Netflix make that hop at
home yeah you'd need to kill daredevil
cuz the master says he needs it
you all wish is my command
nobody's no yours to do with as you will
master again I don't know for sure I'm
in conspiracies every mode moments like
this I get into conspiracy theory mode
it can't help because everyone's
answering to someone it's just some
[ __ ] illogical that daredevil would
just get sliced like this but in this
saturated market on Netflix like Netflix
has created daredevil was the thing that
me and people like me people I know we
all recognize that we're like I had
Daredevils coming out I don't know
really when anything else is coming out
when his premiere date is daredevil is
the thing I gave a [ __ ] about on there I
feel like it's the thing a lot of people
gave a [ __ ] about well that in
Castlevania like those are the two that
I kept up on I got really excited when
they were gonna premiere this neat dude
they learned a lot of stuff like if
you're just looking at the Disney
properties as properties on a Monopoly
board Disney would own that much of the
Monopoly board it's crazy so I can see
them being like I'll trade you this for
B&O Railroad so I can have all the
railroads to which I mean when I heard
about the Disney streaming service I was
like I'm not subscribing to the Disney
streaming service and if this was a move
to have daredevil gets sliced from
Netflix so daredevil season four could
premiere on the Disney streaming service
I repeat Disney I'm not gonna subscribe
to your [ __ ] streaming service that
doesn't make any sense
the daredevil is like fighting in blood
and heads getting smashed in doors and
titties it's not gonna feel like it's at
home and the Disney streaming service
what if it goes there will be like some
rated pg-13 max version of daredevil
there is that there's no logic in that
move I guess it's just gone
it's either gone or that's a really dumb
thing they're about to do to daredevil
by putting it on the Disney streaming
service I don't know I feel like I'm
adding nothing to this conversation
nothing anyone didn't already know and
if or nothing else I'm just theorizing
if not yelling at my camera cuz I'm just
irritated and as a fan it's just
frustrating cuz I feel like it's just
like there's a bunch of chess pieces
moving around and we fans are just kind
of caught in the middle and we as fans
can never feel calm about anything
because our favorite show might get
sliced cuz it might just be a move among
studios cuz I feel like it may live on
elsewhere is Hollywood studio [ __ ]
speak for ya there are wheels turning
and a business move is the reason this
move happen alright so daredevil getting
canceled off of Netflix what do you
think about it and why do you think it
happened whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you're seeing here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]